at this altitude I can flat out for my
hands this episode is brought to you by
Inc tel and I've used them personally
ever since I wrote the 4-hour workweek
I've been asked over and over again how
I choose to delegate tasks how I do
80/20 analysis and so on at the root of
many of those decisions is a simple
question actually two questions number
one how can I invest money to improve my
quality of life I use that in investing
as well the second how can I spend a
little money or moderate money to save
significant time Inc tella is one of
those investments they're a turnkey
solution for all of your imaginable
customer care needs
I used Intel during the launch of the
4-hour body which was very very involved
and they provided 24/7 customer service
for my land rush campaign because it was
critical for me to take care of every
person who purchased my books and
participated this allowed me to focus on
the things that I am better at my
strengths like the marketing plan that
we'd worked on for six months
implementing that Intel trains their
experience customer service reps to know
your business and your products inside
and out and make your customers raving
fans they answer more than a million
customer service requests every year and
they can do so across all platforms
including email phone social media text
even chat leaving your customers with
poor service or just mediocre service
which by the way in a competitive pool
is a huge liability long wait times or
unanswered messages carries a massive
cost and risk to your business Intel
removes the logistics and headaches of
this type of communication allowing you
to focus on your strengths and grow your
business it can be a real competitive
advantage and I see many many e-commerce
companies
and the tech companies thinking of
customer service as a good enough check
box or an afterthought and just like
Airbnb used design and innovative ways
to be a competitor and to win you can do
the same thing with customer service so
as a listener of this podcast you can
get up to ten thousand dollars off
that's a big discount ten thousand
dollars off your startup fees and costs
by visiting Inc Telecom forward slash
Tim so check it out for more info go to
Inc Telkom i NK te l comm forward slash
Tim this episode of the Tim Farriss
shows brought to you by linked in the
write higher can make a huge impact on
your business the wrong hire can create
your business and I have seen example
after example from thousands of my
readers at a minimum where they've told
me stories of how finding the right
person at the right time and in some
cases not even asking what should I do
but asking who should I find because
that person can help me determine what
exactly to do more intelligently and
I've had a chance to hire two such
people in the last year and that has
just made my business take a quantum
leap forward and my complexity in my
personal and business life get cut
dramatically and this type of
simplification cannot be overvalued we
think a lot about hiring and I think a
lot about hiring and it is a skill that
I've had to learn it is important to
find the right person but where do you
find that person you can post a job on a
job board and hope that that right
person finds your job that they are on
the internet happening to scan something
here and there and then find you but
think about it how often do you hang out
on job boards the answer is probably not
very often so don't leave finding
someone great to chance when you can
post your job exactly where people go
every day to make connections grow in
their careers and discover job
opportunities that is linked in most
LinkedIn members haven't recently
visited the top job boards but 9 out of
10 men
are open to new opportunities and with
70% of the US workforce on LinkedIn
posting there is the best way to get
your job opportunity in front of more of
the right people and you can be very
very highly targeted and specific people
who are qualified for the role you have
and ready for something new this is
where you find them it's the best way to
find that person that key person who
will help you grow your business and
this is why a new hire is made every 10
seconds using LinkedIn that's bonkers
every 10 seconds so head to linkedin.com
forward slash Tim and get $50 off your
first job post that's a linkedin.com
forward slash Tim tea I am to get $50
off your first job post linkedin calm
forward slash tim take a look terms and
conditions do apply why hello boys and
girls lads and lasses madams and
monsieurs this is Tim Ferriss and
welcome to another episode of the Tim
Ferriss show where it is my job to
deconstruct world class performers what
on earth does that mean it means teasing
out lessons learned habits routines
favourite books etc from people who are
at the top of their field or fields and
that can range from business to sports
from chess to you name it military
strategy and this episode we have an
icon I would say is a fair descriptor
Eric Schmidt at Eric Schmidt who is
technical advisor and board member to
alphabet Inc where he advises its
leaders on technology business and
policy issues
Eric joined Google in 2001 and helped
grow the company from a Silicon Valley
startup to a global leader in technology
he served as Google's chief executive
officer that CEO from 2001 to 2011 an
executive chairman from 2011 to 2018
alongside founders Sergey Brin and Larry
Page he has some incredible stories and
his career is is just incredible to
consider and discuss we get into lots of
specific
takeaways lessons etc under his
leadership Google dramatically scaled
its infrastructure and diversified its
product offerings while maintaining a
strong culture of innovation and he
believes that innovation can be
systematized by the way and we get into
what that means
Eric serves on the boards of the Mayo
Clinic and the Broad Institute among
others his philanthropic efforts through
the Schmidt Family Foundation focus on
climate change including support of
ocean and marine life studies at sea as
well as education specifically
cutting-edge research and technology in
the natural sciences and engineering he
is founder of Schmidt futures which
works to improve societal outcomes
through the development of emerging
science and technology he's also the
co-author of several books the new
digital age how Google works and his
latest book trillion dollar coach it's a
hell of a title subtitle the leadership
playbook of Silicon Valley's Bill
Campbell which he co-authored with
Jonathan Rosenberg and Alan Eagle I've
been fascinated by Bill Campbell for
decades and when I moved to Silicon
Valley in 2000 I wanted to someday have
a chance to speak to him directly
unfortunately he passed away several
years ago
and in this conversation I finally get
to ask a lot of the questions I've
always wanted to ask about Bill Campbell
who mentored or better put coached a
who's who of people in Silicon Valley
and did it without getting paid it's a
crazy meaning he chose not to get paid
it's such a wild story and it was an
incredible opportunity to have a chance
to sit down with Eric to discuss that
and much more from his life so without
further ado please enjoy this
conversation with Eric Schmidt and for
more info on the book which I highly
recommend checking out you can go to
trillion-dollar coach.com
enjoy
Eric welcome to the show thank you for
having me so if we flash-forward and I'm
sure we will jump around in in a very
nonlinear fashion when I look at your
your undergrad experience is it true
that you started in architecture and
then shifted to electrical engineering
that's right you know software didn't
really exist at the time computer
science didn't really exist as a field I
had been programming when I was in high
school it was a rare event at the time
when I meet some fifteen-year-old boy
that has three computers and is a gamer
and sits at home with all sorts of
screens all night that was me back then
without the computers without the gaming
of without the screens so when I went to
college I actually applied as an
architect because I had studied
architecture in high school and I liked
it but I wasn't a very good architect
but I was quite a much better engineer
and when I got to freshman year I was a
good enough programmer that I skipped
the freshman year programming and that's
the hallmark of a flexible college
program is they organized around my
ability so I was what we now call an
early developed nerd although the term
wasn't even used back then what did you
like about architecture what drew you to
architecture initially I've always liked
building things and I've always liked
structure and I've always been pretty
analytical and what's interesting about
computer science is computer science is
about scale and sort of scale of systems
and organizing systems it's all the same
stuff right so I found in architecture
and where again I didn't have the
artistic sense but I had this scale
since it's the same skillset and we're
gonna talk I suspect quite a bit about
mentorship coaching mentors and coaches
in this conversation and I thought we
could look at a few periods in your past
to talk about influences people you've
learned from
and we can certainly jump all over the
place if anyone comes to mind that I
don't prompt but around 1983 and I'm
skipping quite a bit of course you
joined Sun Microsystems what for people
who don't know what what did
Sun Microsystems do and was there anyone
who comes to mind as having taught you a
lot while you were at Sun so one of the
things to think about when you look at
your phone or your Macintosh or your PC
is that there were whole waves of
predecessors of these things that were
impossibly slower and impossibly more
expensive but had those things not
occurred we wouldn't have gotten to
where you are today
so each generation builds this product
that's impossibly difficult so son
managed to build what was impossible at
the time which was a 1 megahertz
processor a 1 megabyte memory and a 1
megabit screen today your phone has a
gigabit that is a thousand or more times
more than that and we sold products for
$50,000 to engineering design systems
because they were busy doing technical
things and that's how it started the
workstation as it was known was actually
based on something called an alto that
was invented at Xerox PARC which at
which I had worked with before and the
workstation that that was invented at
Xerox Alto Park was also the predecessor
of the Lisa which was the predecessor of
the Mac so again the provenance of these
things are these very early research
prototypes there were a few hundred
Altos built you can see they're in
museums today what I will tell you about
them is that they are impossibly slow
compared to what yesterday but they
seemed enormous ly powerful at the time
and you'll and how did you end up at Sun
and did anyone in particular
take you under their wing or impart
lessons to you while you were there
so in my story what happened was I was
at Berkeley and my best friend was a
brilliant computer scientist named Bill
joy who was the chief programmer of much
of the technology of the time he did
much of the early internet programming
and when I was at Xerox I worked with
another brilliant computer scientist
named Butler Lampson so I had the best
best smartest mentors in the technical
sense so I had a choice of staying and
doing research but I really wanted to go
into a company my friend Bill had
founded Sun Microsystems which was this
technical platform at the time and I
showed up and what happened was there
were a couple of exec I had knew nothing
about business I figured he was like
fine and there were some technical
founders they had brought in a
professional CEO it's all very scrappy
and within a month of my starting there
was a gentleman named Bernie look crew
who was bought in he was impossibly old
at 39 they're to be in my 20s and he had
he knew everything he knew every he'd
been through everything I was so
impressed by he knew how to build
products he understood politics inside
of a company he understood how to get
things out the door he had worked at
Digital Equipment Corporation so again
the management style of that generation
imparted to the next generation Digital
Equipment Corporation was subsequently
purchased by a series of other companies
including Hewlett Packard Sun was
eventually purchased by Oracle where you
can buy their products today so again
that the the technology is such that 30
years earlier that knowledge base
survives in the heads of the people who
were there and in the legacy of the
intellectual property that they invented
and I guess the same will be true thirty
years from now for what we're talking
about
and you mentioned bill joy I'm going to
come back to Bill joy a little bit later
but I've only had a few people on this
podcast the people who are on this
podcast tend to be well-spoken but I've
only had a few
on who seemed to speak in nearly
finished prose and he seemed to be on
that short list have you always been as
clear a communicator as you are or is
that something that you developed and if
so or honed and if so how I don't know
to be honest I'm just this is who I am I
think what happens is that I'm a very
logical thinker and I'm a good explainer
so logical thinker plus good explainer
is how it works and I also try very hard
to observe things around me and try to
figure out how things work and that's
been sort of my secret to having a
little luck around me but going back to
mentors so Bernie was an incredible
force because he was also tough and he
was also clear and he was also precise
and he would get upset if we weren't
working hard enough on something and he
pushed us and I learned something I was
a very polite nice scientist coming out
of academia I learned that in business
you need to be pushed you need somebody
says we're going to go do this and were
to push it very hard and he really
trained me in the executive arts if you
will I worked for him for a decade what
we're I'd love to talk about those
executive arts because in my experience
this isn't a uniform of course but some
technologists view say the sales side or
the management side with some degree of
disdain that's not true across the board
but it's it's somewhat common sentiment
what were some of the executive arts or
the lessons that you learned at that
time it's important to say right now
that today we know much more how to run
successful tech companies that we did in
the 1980s and 90s the formulas the
learning the standards of excellence are
far far more honed over the last 20
years of executives working in each
other companies and things like that
that's part of why things happen so fast
in our industry
but at the time we didn't really know
how to professionally release
we're in this new space we didn't really
have open source software established as
a principal we didn't really know how to
sell it we figured we would sell direct
but how do we do that what kind of
salesman did we hire so in that period
it was much more raw than it sounds in
hindsight we honestly didn't know do we
hire a blue suited salesman who looks
good and talks a lot do we hire somebody
who's very technical because our
customers were technical how do we goal
them how do we listen to them we those
of us on the technical side found the
salespeople very entertaining because
all they did was talk and we would sit
there and eventually I was so curious
for this I asked one of the salespeople
to actually come and present the
engineers what two salespeople do and
what he did is he got up and he said
look my job is to talk people until they
buy things and we all said well what do
you how do you actually do that said
that's why I'm always on the phone and I
don't want to have dinner with you I
want to have lunch with you because I
don't have dinner with my family so so
we learned a lot of a high-end sales and
sales cycles that have since become the
norm and these big-ticket items
what's interesting is the industry has
some too removed away from that now that
the industry has gone from more b2b -
b2c that is consumer businesses and a
big change from that son period is now
our industry is a consumer focused in
the industry with many many successful
such companies mm-hmm and you you are a
very good and clear explainer and feel
free to fact-check me on this but I
believe you've taught at Stanford GSB at
the Graduate School of Business and did
you teach with Peter Wendel the
entrepreneurship and venture capital
class that's correct
I'm also teaching a class on artificial
intelligence applied to science at
Caltech another fantastic institution
I've spent some time with Peter because
I went to Princeton undergrad and had a
chance to hear him as a guest speaker
and then went to GSB to
sit in on his class when he was teaching
many many years ago back when I had more
hair and in that class are there any
particular resources or books that you
like to point people to for those who
want to learn like you said a lot a lot
of things have been codified in the last
few decades what's interesting is a lot
of the things that I'm talking about are
still not written down from the
engineering science perspective how do
you manage a large software project I'm
not aware of a the defining book that
describes that there's plenty of
technical books about aspects of
software but the culture of software is
still evolving an example is that a
recent change is to essentially a pair
programming where somebody writes code
another one checks it there are
languages a recent language is called
the NGO language which actually is
designed around that principle right so
we just presume that that's how
programming is done these were all
things that were not worked out at the
time without plugging my own books too
much we teach how Google works in in
Peter Wendel in my class at Stanford
which is very very highly ranked class
and I having just done it I still think
that the basic lessons that we talk that
we talk about and how Google works which
are fundamentally that it's the product
it's the product it's the product its
recruiting its recruiting its recruiting
and transparency of how you operate are
sort of the key lessons that we learned
and they're codified in that book and I
think we can begin segue towards Google
because we're going to spend quite a bit
of time on it and we may hit some of the
intervening chapters along the way you
mentioned bill joy earlier and as you
mentioned
legendary for his prowess as a as a
programmer who also then spent some time
as a venture capitalist and it it's when
I look at it was an interviewer talk
that you've given this is actually all
in the Stanford GSB site you mentioned
an approach that he had one of his
approaches so he
find an area of interest look up
research papers about it he would figure
out the two or three best authors and
then call them and you know by the way
these are people who no one ever calls
so they would call him right back and
then he would ask them what's the most
interesting thing in your field and I
bring this up because I am say going to
another venture capitalist named John
doar and but before we get into the role
that John played according to my reading
at least in your introduction to Google
what what who is John doar what makes
him special
you can answer that of course in any
order well John was this mythical figure
that I met when I first joined Sun he
seemed everywhere and he was one of
these prodigies at sales he had worked
at a company called Compaq and he'd been
so successful as a salesperson that he
had joined kleiner perkins which became
the most successful venture firm in
history and was so for a long time and
he was on the board of Sun and Compaq
and a number of other companies and it
was critical it was interesting to me
was I learned a lot from John because he
had a pretty simple rule which is that
what do venture capitalists do they help
the management team they recruit
management team and they raise money so
his job is was once you had identified a
company you invest in it you were all in
on that company and kleiner perkins at
the time was the highest return highest
gross margin highest lee paid partners
of any of them and interest in the
Bernie who was my mentor and coach if
you will went to kleiner perkins after
he left son
and a number of other people including
Vinod Khosla did as well so it's the
world is much smaller than it seems if
you're an outsider looking at our world
some of you think it's this vast world
but to me it seems like about a hundred
people and they all know each other
they've all been on each other's boards
they were all working together toward a
common goal I've since learned that this
is how industries develop so when you go
back to the starting of the automobile
industry or the starting of any
industry they it was a small community
and everyone benefited by working
together even if they were competing as
an Assad when I first came to Google I
developed a habit of calling Terry Semel
who was the then CEO of Yahoo was our
primary competitor congratulate him for
every deal he got and he developed a
habit of calling me to congratulate me
for my getting every deal and the reason
aside from being a good person which he
was was we knew that if he got a
customer to buy our their product we
would shortly follow into that account
and he knew that if we got a customer
using this he knew that he would shortly
follow into the account so there's a
real camaraderie around sharing the
building of these new network platforms
these new sort of forces of good if you
will and they're they're a relatively
small group for much of their time it
also seems like and this is just one
theory that I've come across when people
are trying to explain why Silicon Valley
happened where it did that non-competes
in California being difficult to enforce
seem to have also played a role in in a
lot of that formation and we don't have
to take too much time for that but I
thought that was do you find that sort
of a plausible contributing factor when
you have say the national semiconductor
and these other outlets you yeah so so
true in one in thirty Seconds the
history of the valley was that it
started with the Fairchild Fairchild
corporation and then late 1950s and then
a group of eight left they were called
the traitorous eight and they went to
Intel and a number of other companies
and they were funded by this guy named
Arthur Rock and he was the only venture
capitalist as I interviewed him for
something else I was doing he's now
elderly and retired but incredibly
impressive and I said well what was
venture like back then and he said well
we were the only one so we would just
wait until we just
did how long would you make people wait
oh six weeks eight weeks we were the
only money and a half and he had been
clever enough to figure out the limited
partner structure which fueled this
industry so you have Arthur Rock and
Intel and then the beginnings of the
semiconductor industry and then the
beginnings of Apple and Steve Jobs and
and all of these sorts of things that we
know about but he was very much at the
time of a Lee that was full of technical
people because of national semiconductor
Lockheed and things like that
essentially engineers and they had
typically come out of Stanford so
Stanford's contribution was significant
once the business started going the fact
that there was not a non-compete meant
that people all lived essentially with
each other right they went to each
other's parties there were in marriage
as if you will everybody knew each other
and from that strength they lifted all
of us when I was young and I joined Sun
I didn't realize that there was a half
generation above me that had built this
edifice of venture funding corporations
tech startups and so forth which funded
during that period Microsoft Apple
Google Oracle and a few others yeah it's
it's the do you think Silicon Valley is
a non-recurring phenomenon do you think
that there there are or will be areas
that resemble Silicon Valley in terms of
positive characteristics for
Entrepreneurship so this of course is a
raging debate in the world and the thing
Silicon Valley has going for it or at
least historically abundance of land
great opportunity plenty of money to
tremendous technical universities in
Berkeley and Stanford this history of
entrepreneurial nature of things a sense
of of going higher than others this is
the moonshots versus Roof shots there is
a set of there are a set of people who
also believe that the nature of
California is part of it there was a
book written that some of this happened
this is before
my time because of the anti-war
activities in the 60s and LSD and so
forth and that the kind of crazy
thinkers of the time again before me
ended up here and that also helped
program the area so they would think
broader or higher I don't know if that's
true or not but I will tell you that in
order to replicate Silicon Valley you're
going to need to have leading
universities lots of money and time we
have evidence that Cambridge says the
Cambridge Massachusetts has done this if
you look at biotech they've clearly
built a model very similar we have
evidence that New York is on its way it
looks like there's enough money enough
people enough universities they're
obviously a great draw of a city and we
have evidence that Beijing has the same
feeling when you go to Beijing you get
that same feeling of crazy startups so
those are a few Tel Aviv is another one
we need more competitors than the ones I
just named we need twenty competitors 30
competitors 40 competitors yeah it's
it's it's been fascinating to visit like
you mentioned Tel Aviv Singapore
and many other cities that are trying to
replicate some certainly more
successfully than others but if we if we
come back to Silicon Valley and we come
back to John Doerr when I'm and when
like you said he for a long time was
this mythical being I mean he is the the
the best-known of the best-known venture
capitalists and when I moved to Silicon
Valley in 2000 certainly that was the
case what role did he have in
introducing you to Google I had known
John for a very very long time because
he was on the board of Sun when I was
there for 14 years and I happened to be
at a fundraiser a political fundraiser
at John Chambers house who was the CEO
of Cisco and John came up to me that is
John Doerr came up to me says you should
check out Google and I said it's a
search engine and he goes yes and
they're looking for a CEO and said it
won't amount to much he said look
you really will enjoy it you'll enjoy
meeting the founders I had briefly met
Larry who seemed very smart but
relatively quiet and so he encouraged me
to come and we had a and we and that's
kicked it off so I owe the fact that I'm
at Google to John doar and you go to
meet Larry and Sergey and it I don't
have too many of the specifics but as I
understand it they had a bio of you or
something like that up on a wall a bunch
of food and then proceeded to have what
type of conversation what what picture
so what's interesting is that somehow we
arranged the time I show up and it's an
old building that I used to manage when
I was at Sun so that's weird so I'm
walking into a building which has now
got this Google stuff in it and it's
sort of haphazard a typical sort of tilt
up Silicon Valley so I go up and they
have a single office which they share
they have a projector and they're
projecting my bio on the equivalent of
Wikipedia up again this is unusual they
had lots of food in front of them and I
thought okay and interesting and they
start to question me and they were very
interested in what I'm doing at Novell I
was a CEO at the time and they had
decided that what I was doing at Novell
made no sense at all and they wanted to
make sure that I knew this so this went
on for an hour and a half and it was
rough I mean they were very sharp and I
remember as I walked out of the building
thinking boy I haven't had that good of
an argument in years and that was what
intrigued me the the story by the way is
the thing we were talking about were
called technically called proxy caches
they accelerate the internet and they
believed at the time that you didn't
need them and I believe that you did
after we purchased YouTube the way we
handled the extraordinary growth in
growth of YouTube is we built proxy
caches so what I like to say is they
were right and then I was right
so we both were right is a proxy cache
and this is I'm gonna show how ignorant
I am technology but similar to a content
delivery network in any way yes a CDN is
made out of proxy caches so a typical
typical thing you the simplest example
is a new movie comes out and everybody
wants to watch it online it makes no
sense to send it all from the same place
it much makes much more sense to keep
local copies near you so if you're in
Uzbekistan it doesn't have to go all the
way to Atlanta Georgia
there's a copy locally and the Internet
is good about making those transient
copies transparent to you and keep them
up to date and that's what that is about
and YouTube is now the by far the
largest such consumer of such things and
made an enormous difference in terms of
its bandwidth I guess
Netflix would use the same thing what
types of questions did they ask you or
what made their questioning different
from others it was a stimulating debate
well maybe what made it so because
they're brilliant and because they are
so technically current they can ask the
really hard questions and this is
something that very few founders can do
Bill Gates could do it as an example but
most founders couldn't but they could
and that that told me that the team that
they had assembled could really address
the hard questions their position was
the the that their technical argument
was that there's not an imbalance in
bandwidth and that was true at the time
although it was not true once video took
off and how did they assess you as a
potential leader not just a a not just
your technical capabilities I'm not sure
they had interviewed for about 18 months
before me and they'd like to spend a lot
of time with their people their
candidates so they would go on vacation
for the day or go skiing with a
candidate or so forth to judge cultural
fit
it became fairly quickly clear that I
would be a good fit because we had a
although we were different in age we had
had the same faculty members 18 years
apart and we had a very similar
technical background
they were infinitely smarter than I was
infinitely more current but I had been
like them 20 years earlier and what did
what did John see in you that he thought
they needed my understanding again
you'll have to ask John my understanding
is that the two venture capitalists when
they had invested wanted to bring in
somebody who had operating experience
this came to be turned to adult
supervision and and my understanding is
part of the initial investment that
Sequoia and Google made is that's what
triggered their recruiting when when we
finally came to a deal which didn't take
very long because I obviously I didn't
interview anywhere else I love these
guys I wanted to work with them I
remember one of them saying to me we
don't need you now but we will need you
in the future so understanding that my
experience with growth companies was
quite relevant and so I said the way we
worked which worked well was they were
the technical experts and what I set out
to do was to build the company and I
want to definitely dig into that because
he talked about scale and systems our
systematizing he as early as when we
discussed architecture at the beginning
of the conversation and in a piece and
fortune magazines from a while back 2015
the quote that I have here feel free to
correct it of course is my role was to
manage the chaos you need to have
someone to run fast and have a good
product sense that was Larry and Sergey
my job was to organize the world around
them what were some of the systems or
policies or rules anything that you put
in place to help manage the chaos well
when I arrived
the company was full of brilliant people
but it was sort of wandering around they
would have staff meetings that we're
very very interesting but not very
structured mm-hmm
they lacked at the time somebody to run
all their product strategy general
counsel those sorts of things so what I
did is I put in place just a management
structure pretty straightforward so we
had a meeting on Mondays where we would
run the company we had a meeting on
Wednesdays where we would do product
strategy and we had a meeting on Fridays
where we would look at customers and
this was organized so that the sales
lead could leave town Monday night in
return Thursday night to wherever he
needed to go we've changed that many
times since but simple ways of getting
an activity organized was my initial
task the other thing is that we had to
build a corporation and so we wanted to
hire people who could sort of grow and
build build teams we had three product
managers who were saw our command gar
Susan Wojcicki and Marissa Meyer Marissa
of course ultimately became the CEO of
Yahoo Susan is the CEO of YouTube and
Salah invented the ad system so these
were people of enormous consequence but
at the time they were just individual
contributors so someone had to develop
them we hired this fellow Jonathan
Rosenberg who is the co-author on
trillion-dollar coach and this this may
not be something worth exploring but
it's come up in my in my reading so I
thought it might be worth opening up and
maybe there's something there could you
describe or explain what these 70-20-10
model is if that's the right term to use
that's correct so this was Sergey x'
idea and the question was how do we
organize our resources in terms of core
things new things and experimental
things so Sergey and we had an off-site
and with whole management team and I
still remember and Sergey got up on the
board and he did some math he's a
brilliant mathematician
and at the end of the math he said the
right answer is 70 2010 70% on your core
business 20% on adjacent or nearby
things and 10% on wild bets and he said
that all of these numbers are right you
need the 70% because you need the
revenue the revenue growth you need the
20% because you need to extend your
franchise and you need the 10% which is
crucially important for the things that
you will want to do five or ten years
from now and so we would measure 7 to
2010 and try to make sure that the earth
that the urgent was not overwhelming the
important so there's a good example of
how it worked it was Sir gays idea it
was sir gays math I took it over in the
sense of I think it made perfect sense
and we measured it and we ran the
company that way and the reason I
highlight this is I believe that you can
systematically manage innovation you'll
never be able to pick which of the 50
ideas are going to be the next
billion-dollar corporation it's too hard
but you can manage it so that when you
get these shots on goal you identify
them you get a chance to fund them you
look at them you can systematize
innovation even if you can't completely
predict it when Google starts to take
off you have a lot of brilliant people
you are starting to add structure how
did you at that time of course later and
certainly now you have many different
systems in place but in the very early
days how did you manage the what I would
imagine to be a very large volume of
inbound and you I would probably landing
in your inbox at that time yeah I think
that that's what happens with a hyper
growth company you know growing doubling
every year is pretty easy it's when
you're quadrupling every year now that's
insane and you make you begin to make
mistakes in particular when people are
trying to contact you if you fail to
actually deal with them you can create
an
enemy or at least annoy them so it's
sort of bad management so things would
slip through the cracks
one of the things to know is that when
you're in a high-growth situation you've
got to focus on the right things it's
very very easy to get distracted in a
high-growth scenario the most right
thing is to make your product better in
other words product product product
product because if you have a very
strong product it's relatively easy to
sell it's relatively easy with a very
strong product to make money from it
it's relatively easy to recruit people
to work on it if you have a weak problem
our product is very different so so it
famously was a product company not
anything else and that was again because
of the strengths of the founders with me
helping them and does that does that
then help you for instance if you're
getting just making up a number a
hundred it's probably more like a
thousand who knows email a day to filter
for product related communication or or
prioritizing for internal team first
than any external I know this is a very
graphic but I can tell you that that as
the CEO that my most important thing to
do is to make the velocity of
interactions faster so the moment I get
an email I deal with it immediately
which is typically to send to somebody
else to deal with it so everything that
lags through me is slowing it's like
molasses is slowing the company down so
I am about spin rate gives an example if
you want to R in the but win the bike
race in the marathon bike race the best
way to do it is to establish a spin rate
and hold that spin rate constant just
chug chug chug chug chug chug at the
same rate and you eventually get there
and you do really well so my theory of
management was just to run at the same
heist
seven days a week and that meant that
every email get forwarded every issue
was addressed and so forth and that sort
of heads down focus I think is a key in
very high-growth environments you
mentioned earlier having and we're gonna
segue to someone you alluded to it in
just a moment the trillion dollar coach
the one version of weekly meetings you
had Monday running the company Wednesday
product I think it was Friday customers
for yourself
did you also have they might have been
the same schedule but it and thinking of
a conversation with Jack Dorsey where he
described something similar right having
instead of having five different pieces
of the business being discussed every
day breaking it out so there are daily
clear priorities whether it's the sort
of administrative organizational stuff
product or otherwise for you to help the
company maintain that spin rate did you
have what did your weekly schedule look
like and that might be a bad question
but I just want to see if there's a well
in there well we initially did the
Monday Wednesday Friday but remember at
that time we didn't have to travel the
sales guy had to travel but the rest of
us didn't as the company grew there was
much more much more physical traveling
so we ultimately resolve to a Monday
Tuesday structure most corporations have
a Monday or a Tuesday meeting and then
that allows for the rest of the week to
people to travel and Walmart by the way
is the inverse they have the week the
managers are expected to be out in the
field they fly back on Friday night and
then they meet on Saturday morning after
to incorporate exercises if I exercise I
mean physical exercise so these
gathering traditions are very very
important if I had my own way the way I
would run the company is I would meet
every day at 4:00 because - if you
operationally things happen every day
and they can be quick what I've noticed
in the political
campaigns that I've observed is that
they typically have a nine a.m. daily
meeting which is kind of an update and
before 9 a.m. everyone kind of figures
out what the crisis will be for the day
and off they go if you look at the White
House the first thing that happens in
most presidencies is that there's the
presidential Daily Brief which is the
issues going on in the world which is
typically a half an hour at 8 a.m. so
for operational jobs it looks to me like
if you're not meeting with your staff
often often in a week you're not you're
not running it tight enough now this
does not mean that I was telling them
what to do these were check-ins
these were issue issue issue and because
we were talking to each other all the
time we had context and then because
that ends up causing you to think short
term you then have to have a separate
process to have an off-site meeting some
kind of strategic discussion some kind
of ideation around what people would
like as opposed to what they're
currently doing you have to do both and
you would choose for the daily meetings
4 p.m. instead of first thing in the
morning is that right yeah but that's
just that's just personal preference but
I think it's one of those things where
if I were to start with a new firm today
the first thing I would say is what is
our idealized meeting frequency and I
think if you asked people what would
work for them you would end up with a
couple of meetings a week they would be
organized around the life schedules and
other personal commitments people have
and it would work it gets harder that
the fundamental problem you have in
global companies is time zones and how
do you accommodate people who are on
videoconference in Europe and things
like that
mm-hm and could you please tell me who
Bill Campbell is because I want us to
make sure we segue there okay so
Jonathan Allen and I have written a book
called trillion-dollar coach and Bill
Campbell is in Lisa in our opinion the
most successful coach in world history
he was the primary coach for Google and
its rise it was also the primary coach
for Apple in its rise along with a host
of other
companies and the some of the companies
that he has coached have now exceeded
more than two trillion dollars of value
so it gives you a sense of the value
that he was he helped create his
background was that he was a football
coach at Columbia and we pointed out
many times to build it he wasn't
particularly successful although he
tried very hard maybe it's because he
was at Columbia we don't really know but
he was an extraordinary coach of humans
and so in my first year at Google John
Doerr who had placed me here at Google
said you need a coach and I said I don't
need a coach I'm really good and he said
after some back-and-forth he said we'll
do tennis players have coaches and I
said yes and then he got me I had to say
okay so we met and then the rest is
history now he has just an incredible
and I do mean incredible in the literal
sense I mean an incredible resume right
as you said he had this coaching career
and then he seemingly segwayed it into
into technology and you go down the list
and you have Bezos Marissa Mayer Steve
Jobs Sheryl Sandberg yourself what what
made him different right like why why
it's it's important to explain why
coaching matters you hear all the day
that I need a mentor well by the way you
need a mentor and I need a mentor
mentors are great that's not what Bill
was Bill was a coach and more
importantly he was the best coach of
teams ever and why do you need a team
because a company is not an individual
it's a team of individuals who need
coaching to achieve their objective so
hit all those skills that he built over
those many years ultimately culminated
in this enormous success that he had
unfortunately he died about three years
ago but I think his legacy will live on
forever in the valley the the thing that
did is he understood how to coach teams
of people who were themselves
competitive with each other and I
mention this because you know you would
assume that if you go to a company as
you get higher and higher you're dealing
with it very sophisticated very educated
very experienced seasoned professionals
they'll know what to do well in fact not
only do they not know what to do but
they're all caught up in their own
politics and their own egos and they
disagree with each other and they and
they want to make their mark and they
want credit and so forth and a coach
sorts that out in the same sense that a
coach of a football team or a basketball
team does it's the same principle but
applied to business and we were just
talking about a figure we can we can
dive into many different aspects of his
coaching and we talked we were talking
about meetings not too long ago bill
seems to have had very very clear
opinions on how to start and run a
meeting do you or do you recall how he
did how he did that or how he
recommended people do it I do and what's
funny about it is that he was such an
integral coach I can't tell you what
ideas were mine and what ideas were here
all I can say is that we that is he and
I implemented these principles together
which obviously a statement of how good
a coach he really was so for example
meetings tend to be unstructured so his
advice was make a list of things you
want to talk about and then start the
meeting not with that list unless you're
in crisis but start with trip reports
and it because people were traveling
people would spend five or ten minutes
we would often use Google Maps and show
I went from here to here to here but
then that allowed people to
conversationally explain what they were
worried about or what they had observed
this worked incredibly well because it
humanized the organization another thing
that bill did is he made you feel that
he loved you by listening to you as a
person and the thing I learned from Bill
and I'm used to running fast and I'm
used to a blah blah blah and is this
good or bad
fine goodbye right that doesn't work it
doesn't work for junior employees and it
doesn't work for senior employees
they're human too so if you're gonna
manage people or lead them lead the
whole person how are you how is your
family how was your operation what are
you worried about what are you better at
life what do you think about the
political situation what do you think
about the Grand Prix and erase cars
whatever it takes to get people to be
humanized turns out to be key and the
difference between a coach and a manager
this is important is a manager will say
Tim please do this a coach will say Tim
what do you want to do and it he'll
carefully guide you to what you want to
be to what the collective good is that
function is critical imagine if we had
that in our political system I wish we
don't today imagine if we had it in most
companies all of these issues everyone
would be kind of marching in the same
direction so to talk about that what you
want to do I'd love to look at a
specific example which might be related
you can correct me if it's not but so in
2001 bill asked Sheryl Sandberg who was
then at Google what do you do here and
he refused all the traditional answers
until she understood the real answer he
was looking for without her
responsibilities but in what ways she
contributed value every day so did he
ask you that question or why was it
important for him to ask that question
either one of one of those rules was to
get past the slogans and with
experienced executives people who've
been executives for a while you know
sort of ten years of executives let's
say they're in their mid to late 30s or
40s they've they've done it for a while
they're pretty executive at it they get
pretty good at giving you the marketing
answers I'm trying to fulfill my life I
want to make the world a better place
and those marketing phrases he
thought were a waste of time not because
you don't use them to motivate people
but because they don't give you
precision as to what you should be doing
so every day you would get up and your
job was to do something precisely that
you wanted to do that would make the
world a better place and serve the
shareholders or your boss or what have
it whatever it is and you need to be
able to articulate that as a principle
because if you could articulate it to
Bill you could articulate it to anybody
and he was very good at that what do you
want to do and what are you doing he
also you mentioned political factors and
differences of opinion how did he handle
making decisions or facilitating
decisions when people were not meeting
eye to eye let's just say an ax board
meeting he was on a lot of boards I see
if two people who fundamentally disagree
or there's there's a sort of a
loggerhead what what would bill do how
would he handle that well so the rule we
had about meetings was that there was a
decision to make her in the room but the
decision maker in the room did not make
the decision in the room until after
other people had been heard and so there
was a protocol for that so let's say
that I'm the decision maker and you and
you know Maria are having a big argument
so what bill would say look guys why
don't we come back with a joint proposal
and then he would talk to the
individuals and see if he could coach
them to a common agreement even if he
couldn't get them to a common agreement
the fact that they had participated in
the discussion had been heard and saw
the decision being made allowed them to
overcome their embarrassment or envy or
unhappiness that they had lost to go
back and fight for a win and when Google
went public in 2004 bill recommended
that you step aside as chairman and
remain CEO but then he made sure you
would get reinstated as chairman later
what was his thinking behind that or and
how did
pitch that to you there was a
complicated discussion about
independence involving dual class sort
of a technical matter and they had come
to this idea and I thought well I
haven't I've I've done a good job right
I felt I had take I took it personally I
took it wrong it was my pride that that
got to me and so he immediately
recognized that this was a pride problem
right so he said look I get it I
understand it I think this is best for
the company and I in the next year I'll
work to make this reverse in the right
way and his credibility with me by then
this is we started working three years
earlier was so high that I naturally
said okay now imagine if I done
something stupid and allowed my pride to
get ahead of me right so that's the key
thing he did is he understood when
people were hurt their egos were hurt or
they felt that they had been dissed or
not not understood and he could not he
could not cannot mollify them but but
understand them and get them to say
there's a bigger goal here he said Eric
there's a bigger goal here than you and
that worked right and 18 years later it
still worked when he first how did he
first come into the picture when did you
use it three years earlier so what was
you do remember your first meeting with
Bill I had met him when I was at Sun and
he at the time worked at Intuit he the
management at Sun was trying to hire him
into Sun but he said no and I remember
people saying to him he's the
hardest-working executive we've ever met
and they described him as flying to
Japan for a one-hour meeting and then
flying right back which I thought was
insane that was his that was his work
ethic I didn't knew nothing else about
his capabilities so when John doar
called me and said you need a coach I
said yeah yeah I'm a pretty smart guy
and then he convinced me that I had to
have a coach but once I said
with bill I knew I needed a coach and
the way I knew was that he had been
working with another executive who
worked for me at the time inside of
Google and this other executive had a
health problem a very bad cancer problem
and he did not he bill did not tell me
and I thought if bill wouldn't tell me
that then bill must be able to keep
confidences he must be a person who is
going to be on my team keep secrets of
the company protect us and so forth so
it's interesting when you meet somebody
you kind of judge them of are they
sincere are they serious are they
professional and bill was that and I
should say that the first project we
gave bill was to get our product
management functions going I mentioned
the three product management people
getting those structure working with him
to hire people and it worked flawlessly
how long did it take to implement that
that first task I'm just curious how he
went about once he had marching orders
on something like that or had this
jointly decided with someone like
yourself on the March errors well it
wasn't really marking marching order it
was sort of we would have a chat and he
would say what do you think about this
and I said that's great why don't you
see if you can make something happen
there and an example would be that one
day we decided to get rid of all of the
executives inside of engineering because
we didn't weren't happy with their
performance this was called the
disorganize ecute evented up with a
hundred direct report so I told bill go
work on that problem try to figure out
how how are we gonna manage a hundred
people indeed that worked flawlessly
right that it actually worked and
productivity increase it was the right
decision from our founders once again
exactly correct
but that's an example where we were
responding to what the founders wanted
and we did so dramatically and quickly
how does one person manage 100 or is
that is the answer they don't and
there's some
alternate system at play I mean what I
can't not ask people will will harass me
if I don't ask you well remember that I
used the word manage but what I really
meant was lead mm-hmm right so the key
thing to do was to get this one one
person whose name is Bill Koren by the
way who was incredibly talented at
managing large groups get him to be able
to do this is the only time I know in
history of a person successfully
managing such a large flat organization
and of course all of those people are
now heads of major operations within
Google so again their development with
with Bill Correns leadership really made
a difference but there were many many
other examples but Bill and I worked
into a structure where I would meet with
him once a week and he had this habit he
he first place bill was a hugger and
when I say a hugger I mean he would hug
people on the street right so when he
would walk into an office he would light
up his smile everyone would smile
everyone will get a hug and we would sit
down so in my case I would go to his
office I would have to hug his secretary
he would have to hug me he'd have to hug
his secretary and then I would sit down
and he would have written behind the
whiteboard five words and those were the
things would prompt the conversation and
I would ask him to just talk and he
would over minute many minutes talk
about what he had heard and what he saw
and then I would say well why don't we
do this why don't we do that
they worked incredibly effectively he
worked on a similar basis with Steve
Jobs he worked with Steve's every day
until his death including on his health
and he would with Steve he would go for
walks when Steve could walk he visited
him in the hospital he would talk him on
the phone he his house was very near
Steve Jobs his house so he would
literally walk over and serve helping
manage Apple in the same way I am gonna
ask I have a question that involves
Steve but before I do that what what
might there be on the board and among
those five words what types of types it
was the answer it would be the first
name of an executive and
inevitably in trouble over something
there would be some theme like revenue
there would be some product that it was
in trouble that we were having issues
with there was some deal or a customer
that he had heard about he wanted to
make sure I knew about that kind of
thing he's literally one word and how
did he structure his thinking when he
would I mean Europe as as you've
mentioned and as is clear in this
conversation very structured highly
analytical how would he structure that
that talking because he was
fundamentally a coach humanist he would
talk about how the people felt and he
would predict what they were going to do
so here's an example we would have an
executive that we weren't just we
weren't sure if they were doing a good
job or not should we replace them should
we put them in a different job that kind
of thing that was where he was heavily
involved
he was so good that I would have him do
most of the compensation issues if we
had board meeting come up he would call
the board members before the board
meeting to see if there were any
concerns to ruffle any feathers
anticipate if there were some message
that I wanted sent ahead of time I could
say bill why don't you guys let them
know that I'm worried about something
and maybe they'll have some ideas so
people could prepare so he's the perfect
partner to anticipate problems who so in
the same sense that he was a coach of
the team if you will below me or with me
he was also a coach of the board he
played the same role on the Apple board
and I know because I was on the Apple
board for four years with him as the
coach and board member so I'm glad you
brought that up because I'm looking at a
piece from recode net so Kara Swisher
put this up and Kara for those people
who don't know she's been on the podcast
but is quite feared among some in the in
tech circles because she has incredible
sources and she's very direct and very
honest with her messaging so so it can
cut people but she put out a piece after
bills passing that is one of the war
missed things probably the warmers
saying I've ever seen her put out and in
the piece she she cites a passage from a
Fortune magazine for 2014 which is when
he stepped down from the Apple board and
this is this is part of it and then I
have a follow-up question so the highest
profile danger zone was his dual role on
the Apple board and advising Schmidt in
Google quote Steve would say if you're
helping them you're hurting me you would
yell at me or accost Campbell whose
normal lebanner typically needs to be
sanitized for most publications I'd say
I can't do HTML come on I'm just
coaching them on how to run their
company better
end quote he continued in both roles for
years how does someone pull that off
maybe that is just remarkable the quote
is correct and Kara is correct in that
matter bill was not involved in the
product the product decisions as much as
he was in the coaching and he was
careful not to cross the boundaries and
he was also not on the Google board he
was only on the Apple board so again in
hindsight sort of hard to believe but
somehow we all trusted him on both sides
he eventually I think got tired of the
of the tension but from my perspective
he was so honest and so direct that
there was no question he could continue
he you asked about how did he work with
people and I think that that he did a
couple things that were profound his
rule was there would be no gap between
statements and fact that you had to be
relentlessly honest and candid and
direct if there was any kind of a
lighting of the truth he would know it
and he would nail you and he was shall
we say very salty in his language that
kept everybody kind of on and honest and
because of that you both trusted him you
knew that there wasn't a sentence unsaid
and he was also a very good listener so
he did what we call freeform listening
he would literally he listened with
and undivided attention he wasn't doing
his email and checking his iPhone and
those sorts of things you had his
complete attention as a human being and
if you were rambling he would let you
ramble and I can remember repeating
myself seven or eight times I said have
I just repeated myself and he said it's
okay
he understood as a coach that I had to
repeat it enough times to believe it hmm
and how would he how is he able to smell
BS or stress test statements so that he
could tell when people were bending the
truth or omitting details I think for
one thing he had massive experience at
doing this and so you get really good at
checking it but remember he also had
many many sources so we would have
executives that would try to do an
end-around around bill and they would
try to sort of sort of you know go back
on message you know this is what I did
and this is why I did it and Bill would
say I'm not sure let's go through that
again
and then if if the person wouldn't tell
bill the truth he would cut them off and
he was pretty ruthless he would come in
and say we can't trust this person we
can't trust this person and we need to
get them out of here
or you know move them out of that job or
whatever he is he was very very very
committed to the goals of the
organization so think about a coach in a
foot you know he's using a football
analogy the goal is not to have the
quarterback run the half the longest
ball throw the goal is to win the game
now if as a byproduct the quarterback
has this amazing achievement that's
great right but it but the moment the
quarterback gets confused right that
we've got a problem so you've got when
you're in the position of coach it's all
about the team it's all about winning in
a business it's relatively
straightforward you have a set of shared
goals which are you know we all agree to
what the goals of the firm are bill was
very very good at keeping everybody on
that message
I'm reading a quote here that I have in
front of me that this was something that
bill apparently said to the CEO of Chegg
dan Rosen's wag and here here it goes
though the last part relates to much of
what you just said I don't take cash I
don't take stock and I don't take [ __ ]
so I do have two questions
by the way that's Bill yeah for the two
five two questions related to that maybe
more the first is how was he compensated
missus he refused compensation so I mean
this was all pro bono yeah and and let
me tell you why he explained that he had
done really well
in his previous job and this was his
give back to the industry right he
wanted to do this and he didn't want to
be confused by money he wanted to work
with people on the principles that he
cared about wild so he this was his
giving back I mean decades of and he had
made enough money you know from his
perspective we did create a foundation
for football players which people
donated to in his honor which he's very
he was very happy about but he's a good
example of one of these people whose he
was very motivated about the happiness
and success of people he was happiest
when we were winning and working as a
team that was his that was his income
that was his success and his personal
life he coached many me coached soccer
he coached he worked with an awful lot
of young football players he was in his
civic duty as principled as he was in
his job coaching companies like Apple
and Google and that now that we're
talking about it it also strikes me that
I don't take cash I don't take stock and
I don't take [ __ ] or somewhat
interrelated in the sense that if you're
not incentivized to maximize your sort
of economic return by biting your lip
that could encourage you to be much more
forthcoming about not taking [ __ ]
it's our other any
other examples of sort of binary lines
that he had or things that he would not
accept well he he had a sort of rule
that you would work the people and then
the problem so if you think about it as
a coach a foot again using football
coach analogy if you got the wrong
player in the wrong position you need to
work on that so over and over again is
this the best person that we can get to
work on this problem is there an
alternative choice what do we need to do
get this perform this person performing
better in their job and then he would
work on the problem what happens in
business is everybody wants to talk
about the problem he wanted to talk
about the people and getting the right
people in the right place hmm how did he
fire people or encourage people to fire
people what was the approach he was a we
would come to a decision pretty quickly
that it wasn't gonna work out and then
it sort of warrant because he had high
credibility he even had high credibility
with people who were in the process of
losing their jobs and so he would go and
say look this is not working out and I
will help you in your next role and that
made an enormous difference which of
course he did can you think of any
particular and if it's possible to give
any any historical examples that'd be
really really helpful
any particular hard challenges that bill
helped you through are there any moments
that look back like that there were
particularly stressful or agonizing or
difficult thorny that he helped you
through well we mentioned this going
public role for me he was very helpful
with the company going public which is a
big moment in a corporation's history
helping us with a venture capitalist
thinking through what the functions were
because of course he had done it many
many times
but I think his there was no great event
it was one of those things where he
would became in the fabric he was so
important to us that he became we start
having him come to my staff meeting
initially had been an outside coach he
actually attended our staff meeting
where he typically didn't say very much
he would make notes and then of course
later would go and work on issues that
seemed to come up
he was very helpful when there there
began to be tensions between Apple and
Google and because he knew both sides he
would sit there there there there were
serious disputes between Steve and some
of the Google executives over some of
the issues in Android versus iPhone for
example and those disputes had to do
with who could do what and intellectual
property and those kinds of things and
he got people to talk to each other that
wouldn't have otherwise been able to
speak so there's a case where having
credibility with both groups was
extremely helpful
hmm you said getting people to talk with
one another who might not otherwise chat
with one oh there's one of the bullet
point facts about bill that I have in
front of me is he taught Marissa Mayer
then CEO of Yahoo how to sit quietly
during a meeting and let less senior
people arrive at a decision
are there other are there any particular
approaches or coaching recommendations
that he would that he's made to you or
that you've seen him make to other
people more than once that fall into
that same category of well I'll give you
an example of that I would get worked up
over some issue and I would violate my
own rules so my own rules are to listen
you know reason and then make him make a
decision collectively and if we can't
make it collectively then I'll force a
decision but everyone so I be
sufficiently worked up or upset that I
would just blurt out the answer and he
would inevitably say come on you know
better than that and so that's an
example where a coach you know because
he's seen me operating he says they
crossed a line there but for some of his
work
or work day / week rituals if any come
to mind he would get up at 5:30 in the
morning he would be on the gym from 6:00
till 7:00 and then so he was an early
riser he had he coached soccer at 3:00
or 4:00 in the afternoon so he would
have to go any at family commitments say
he was typically be in the office from
say eight till two ish and then he would
go coach soccer of course we all worked
much later than that so we would call
him but he for example believed in doing
one thing well so when he was coaching
he wouldn't answer the phone can you
imagine that today right from Steve Jobs
here whatever and he wouldn't respond to
text because he thought that that was an
interruption and what he was doing so he
was one of these principled people of
this is what I'm working on this is what
I'm working on this deserves my full
attention I'm worried that we're losing
that style which I value a great deal
hmm-what what does the what are the
first 60 to 90 minutes of your day look
like I have a curiosity and you've what
it was your routine morning routine look
like during the way I think like what I
will tell you with well let me tell you
how bill and I worked it out his his
structure of life was Monday through
Friday you're just running around with
your head cut off you know as fast you
can make anything move and his rule was
that on Saturday mornings when you wake
up when it's typically quiet that's the
time to sit down and actually think
about what happened in the week go
through everything and get yourself
organized what's your week like what's
your month like and take however long
you take to think just in your own head
am I using my time the most effectively
and so I've tried to do that every day
in the sense that before anything else
happens once I'm awake and up and
running I try to say is this the best
use of my day what am I missing what do
I need to get done what did I forget
yesterday that kind of thing and do you
have a sort of boot-up sequence that is
your default most mornings I mean do you
wake up at the same time each morning I
know this this seems pretty sorta
quotidian but I'm I'm curious if you
have any if you have a set morning
routine at this point when I'm in one
place for a while yes I typically get up
and you know eat something although not
recently I guess I've tried I'm now
trying intermittent fasting to see if
that makes a difference but but in any
case the first thing most people that I
know do is they're online right so
they're checking the news you're seeing
what happened and in in in the the tech
industry is so dynamic the stuff really
does happen overnight and you really do
you really do need to know what happened
one of the tricks is try to focus on
your own news before you have global
news because global news is so addictive
it's like oh my god and oh this happened
oh whatever you can waste all your time
so try to focus on getting your own
world in order what do I care about
today what do I want to work on am I
happy with what I'm doing today if you
were giving advice to someone looking
for a coach a business coach how would
you tell them to vet candidates or what
to look for you know coaching is a
special skill it's like writing there
are people who are great writers there
are people who are great coaches and
there's more than one right so the the
first question is how is this a person
who lights up a room is this a person
who has that natural charisma that
people want to listen to is this this
person who we can get to be part of our
team and then I think it's a question of
hopefully people will follow the
recommendations in our book about how to
actually do it but the coaching is a
highly highly personal thing right when
you have a great coach you love your
coach again go back to athletics people
talk about their coaches in
ever intial terms because they get them
to perform so well let me yeah I want to
ask shift gears just a little bit and
ask you a few questions about
effectively rapid-fire questions that I
like to ask a lot of people who are on
the podcast and we'll wrap up in just a
little bit but before I get to those
what are you hoping that intermittent
fasting will do what benefits are you
are you hoping to drive well and how do
you do it well so the answer is so
there's there's medical arguments
they're not fact that we evolved as
hunter-gatherers where we had relatively
low amounts of food for long periods of
time so fasting was part of being a
hunter-gatherer and that our bodies are
in fact healthier and better when they
eat there they're not continuous grazing
and so there's there's a whole school of
thought that says that the best thing to
do is to not eat for like 16 hours and
then eat a lunch or a dinner or just a
dinner or things like that and people
report that their energy is equal or
better that they lose weight that they
feel better the science is still not
resolved on this but it's worth checking
out yeah for people interested or if you
certainly it sounds like you've done
your homework
Peter of TIA is an MD and Dominic
D'Agostino handful of folks out there
have some really good literature
exploring the benefits of fasting both
intermittent as you're describing say 16
hours and then looking at more extended
say 3 plus day fasts with data that
they're tracking with ketone monitors
and and glucometers and so on so let's
just just jump into a few of these right
and let me just add that one of the
great scourge is of our lives today is
the amount of sugar that everybody's
eating and sugar in the form of
carbohydrates and so forth so
experimenting with these low carb diets
and that sort of thing might be good for
your longevity and certainly of your
short-term health yeah absolutely
lots lots to say there but I'll save my
my long-winded soapbox for another time
do you have any books that you have
gifted the most to other people and and
you've been I'm certainly you have your
own books right the new digital age how
Google works and now a trillion dollar
coach outside of those books are there
any that you've gifted a lot to other
people I think the one that has had the
biggest impact on me and the ones that
I've given the most number of people has
been angels of our better nature and
angels of our better nature is a 700
page book on death and it's written by a
brilliant Harvard professor who talks at
great length about death rates and the
human condition and he sends a lot of
time talking about what happened 200 300
400 500 years ago and when you finish
the book which takes a long time you
conclude that the world is in a much
much better place than it is that it has
been in the past
that a thousand years ago the average
man died in a war and the average woman
died in pregnancy in their 20s and that
a child born today has a very high
likelihood in almost all parts of the
world to live to a natural a natural old
age that's an extraordinary statement
and that's why the people who run around
saying oh the world's falling apart
we've never had it this bad that's just
not true and the data says it's not true
and that's Steven Pinker for people who
want to look that up and it is a it is a
big book 832 pages do you recommend and
gift that book because it delivers hope
in a world where the news favors
catastrophizing or is are there other
reasons that you give it to people
I my own this is my opinion now I think
what's happened is we're surrounded by
information the information that is
emotional and negative occupies too much
of our brains that it crowds out
optimism we've seen an increase in
depression anxiety and so forth which i
think is to some degree connected to
this firehose of negative information
and a person who didn't know would say
oh it is the worst part worst time in
the world and I would say to them if you
think that imagine you're the father of
an 18 year old boy in 1943 who's just
been sent to the German front or worse
imagine that your father of an 18 year
old boy in Germany in 1943 so again
people lose perspective because of the
immediacy effect and also because
there's so much coming at us that I want
to talk about this this may not be
directly related this could be an
overstatement but just depression
anxiety darker more difficult times
let's just say and understanding that on
the macro level I agree with you if if
you read this book certainly if you look
at the data we are in a spectacular time
for yourself just to humanize you a
little bit for people who are listening
because we've talked about many of the
successes many of the the companies
who've been involved with do you have
any favorite failures and by that I mean
failures or difficult really difficult
times that set the stage for later
successes possibly or taught you
something that later ended up having
tremendous value for me the the key
moment in my professional career was the
decision to go to Novell from
and then the decision to leave Novell
and when I was in Novell which was a
hardcore turnaround a difficult business
lots of problems that's where a lot of
the skills that I had not developed when
I was at Sun were developed you don't
really know how a good leader you are
until you face a really hard challenge
but more importantly John Doerr would
never have recruited me to Google from
Sun because it wouldn't have been
appropriate for a board member so the
fact that I had gone to Novell gave me
the training ground that when I got to
Google and there were things that I
didn't like I would call it I would say
it I would push it another thing that
happened was I was my hobby is airplane
flying and I had been training in a
small jet and jet training because it's
life and death they really push you to
make decisions and take command and for
me the jet training they actually at one
point they had a copilot and they told
the copilot to be incredibly unhelpful
without telling me that in order to
train me to be to take command in a
difficult situation in the simulator so
those all contributed to my development
as a strong-willed leader whatever path
you get there you've got to be willing
to take charge and you've got to be
willing to make decisions what Bill
would say is somebody's got to make the
decision have an appropriate process and
make the decision and keep going how did
you first notice that your copilot was
being unhelpful and how did you respond
to that well I'm used to having good
co-pilots and when they start giving you
information that doesn't make sense and
now you've got your flying and your
crisis and he's giving you mal
information you get annoyed but and so
for me it took a while to figure out
that there was something wrong because
I'm so trusting and one of the things
that that that in this particular
copilot scenario they taught me was you
know what's right use every piece of
your body right your hands your eyes
your thinking your experience to
get yourself out of this situation and
if there's something going wrong over
here then if it's not if there's not a
life critical deal with it later and
that prioritization really helped so in
there were many examples in early Google
where there were choices that we would
have around how we set up our revenue
systems or accounting or what we took to
business or so forth but I knew the
answers because I'd been through this at
Novell and I understood that those
decisions to be made in the most
conservative way conservative in the
sense of least aggressive from an
accounting perspective you were
discussing bill earlier you know or just
I should say describing and it seemed to
me at least if I'm reading between the
lines that he had an incredible
intuitive sense and as you mentioned
sort of a humanist bent that would lead
him to focus on how other people were
feeling and the people before the
problem and so on you have superpowers
it would seem in the the of hyper
analytical development of framework and
systems and so on have you found for
instance your exposure to the arts which
I know you have quite a lot of has aided
you in a business sense as well or are
those sort of separate domains for you
as the analytical the primary driver in
business is there a place for the more
intuitive as an aside my Wikipedia page
says that I'm a world's art collector
and that's false and I left it in
because I used it as an example to say
that not everything you read on the
Internet is true you do have involvement
with art though yes that's but let me
but let me answer I want to answer your
question but I did I didn't want to to
not tell the truth yep so I think when
you have a hyper analytical person which
I am and many people of my industry are
you can be tone deaf and anything that
you can do to increase your
understanding if you're like me of how
people are gonna react to things how
people will perceive emotionally what
you're doing is helpful when we started
at Google we would just throw things
across the just throw things out we
didn't worry about what impact they had
maybe they work maybe they didn't but we
fairly quickly learned that we had to
have a whole release process which again
bill and I put in place where we would
judge for example how will this be
perceived should we run this test right
what is the moral framework of it so
businesses are more than just products
at facts they're about people and
emotion and morality
and those we had very good values from
the founders in that regard but
operationally it was important for me
and everyone to remember that these
things have affect people's lives you
have to really think about it how how
would Bill or maybe how did he I don't
know if he did think about the word
success or what that meant to him or to
or what it should mean to other people
do you have any any window into that
well he lived his life the way I'm
talking about him now so he was a
principled person who have high
integrity he expected it from others and
he thought that a successful life was
one well lived that were consistent with
those principles and that where you
could have a purpose that you cared
about that kind of and his job as a
coach was to get everyone to that to
feel that they had achieved that while
collectively getting the team to have
that feeling I will tell you that
there's nothing more fun than having a
very fast-moving team where everyone's
rowing in the same direction right that
feeling of power and that feeling of
excitement and a feeling of energy and
somebody says hey I just have a new idea
hey can we do this hey can I do that I
want to make this phone call is that
okay I said sure great blah blah blah
blah blah right there's nothing like
that in my life
before or after hmm if this is a this is
sometimes a difficult rapid-fire
question the answer doesn't need to be
rapid-fire but the the question I try to
keep short and which is and if it
doesn't go anywhere that's totally fine
too
the the question is this if you could
put a anything on a billboard
metaphorically speaking to reach
billions of people non-commercial a word
a question a quote or recommendation and
image anything does anything come to
mind that you would want the billions of
people to notice and take stock of I
guess for me it's software and
analytical thinking I am a believer that
the next 50 years human society will
have incredibly complicated human
systems so if you think about the things
we deal with every day the judicial
system the political system the prison
system the traffic system what have you
they were architected in a world where
we didn't have a lot of data and we
didn't have a lot of software and we
couldn't really measure everything and I
think a lot of those systems are gonna
get very very thoroughly designed and if
you're going to design those systems
then design based on outcomes you care
about so in prison systems are you care
more about punishment or recidivism as
an example in in economic systems do you
care more about revenue growth or job
growth I would recommend the latter
because jobs are an identity for
everybody so I would prefer an economic
system which maximized job creation over
total revenue so the measurement systems
and the analytics so the sort of
software and analytical systems that are
buildable now should allow us to have
the world we want right
do we care more about one group or
another now our political system which
will vary by country need to allow us to
make this decision
but there is hope for people who are
subject to punishments that don't fit
the crime and economic penalties that
don't fit the work to get addressed
through these through these programs
systematically we know for example that
we can identify bias now in ways we
couldn't before so people who have bias
used against them people who've been
prejudiced against people who are the
victims of these terrible things we have
a way now of both measuring it and I
think eliminating it with good systems
to sign so I think for the next 50 years
the big narrative is going to be who's
designing these systems how they work
what are the values that are in them how
do we measure them and much of the work
that Google does and I do now is related
to using artificial intelligence and
machine learning to try to build these
systems to be more effective against the
goals that our country wants thank you
excellent answer well I think this is a
good place to start to wrap up and this
has been very fun for me so thank you
again for taking the time and I highly
write a highly highly recommend people
check out trillion-dollar coach subtitle
leadership playbook of Silicon Valley's
Bill Campbell which Eric co-authored
with Jonathan Rosenberg and Alan Eagle
bill has been on my mind for so long I
mean four decades at this point and I am
so I have so much regret that I never
had the opportunity to meet him in
person and have waited for a book like
this to come out I mean it's just
incredible that it finally did and I'm
I'm I'm thrilled that that you all put
this together and that people will have
an opportunity to look over the shoulder
of people like yourself and like this
this Who's Who list of entrepreneurs as
they were coached by this incredible
human being not just coach not
just business mind but human being named
Bill Campbell and people can find more I
have certainly feel free to add anything
here but they can find more about it at
trillion-dollar coach calm they can wave
hello to you at Eric Schmidt on Twitter
Linkedin they can find you quite easily
and also onto Facebook Eric Schmidt 76
and I will include links to everything
we've discussed in the show notes Eric
do you have any last words parting
comments recommendations for people
anything you would like to say before we
wrap up with Tim it's been an incredible
privilege to be on on this show when I
think of the way you've communicated the
ideas and the principles you of us
you've established bill would love you
because of what you stand for what's
interesting about our book on Bill is
that Jonathan and Alan and I started
this book just as a thank you to someone
who had been our coach and mentor and
had a huge impact but what we discovered
was that there was essentially no
literature on how to coach teams in
business there was no there were no
facts there were no analogies there was
no way of talking about it so what we
discovered is that the principles that
he taught write us directly are the
universal principles of managing teams
right from football to business and
everyone needs a coach yep this is very
very true I didn't actually get a coach
in this capacity until maybe two years
ago and certainly for people listening
even if you have a small organization
even if you are your organization as a
single person I work with contractors
for instance having a coach even to
simply hold you accountable and and
force you to clarify your thinking is of
it is so leveraged and valuable I'm just
thrilled that that you guys have put
this book out so thank you again I
really appreciate you taking the time
not only
to put together the book but also to
share some of your lessons learned in
this conversation okay well thank you
very much Tim I appreciate it into
everybody listening you can find links
to everything in the show notes as per
usual at tim blog forward slash podcast
and until next time thank you for
listening
hey guys this is Tim again just a few
more things before you take off number
one this is five bullet Friday do you
want to get a short email from me would
you enjoy getting a short email for me
every Friday and that provides a little
morsel of fun before the weekend and
five bullet Friday is a very short email
where I share the coolest things I've
found or that I've been pondering over
the week that could include favorite new
albums that I've discovered it could
include gizmos and gadgets and all sorts
of weird [ __ ] that I've somehow dug up
in the the world of the esoteric as I do
it could include favorite articles that
I have read and that I've shared with my
close friends for instance and it's very
short it's just a little tiny bite of
goodness before you head off for the
weekend so if you want to receive that
check it out just go to 4-hour work week
calm that's 4-hour work week calm all
spelled out and just drop in your email
and you will get the very next one and
if you sign up I hope you enjoyed this
episode of the Tim Ferriss shows brought
to you by linked in the write higher can
make a huge impact on your business the
wrong hire can crater your business and
I have seen an example after example
from thousands of my readers at a
minimum where they have told these
stories of how finding the right person
at the right time and in some cases not
even asking what should I do
but asking who should I find because
that person can help me determine
exactly to do more intelligently and
I've had a chance to hire two such
people in the last year and that has
just made my business take a quantum
leap forward and my complexity in my
personal and business life get cut
dramatically in this type of
simplification cannot be overvalued we
think a lot about hiring and I think a
lot about hiring and it is a skill that
I've had to learn it is important to
find the right person but where do you
find that person you can post a job on a
job board and hope that that right
person finds your job that they are on
the Internet happening to scan something
here and there and then find you but
think about it how often do you hang out
on job boards the answer is probably not
very often so don't leave finding
something great to chance when you can
post your job exactly where people go
every day to make connections grow in
their careers and discover job
opportunities that is linked in most
LinkedIn members have it recently
visited the top job boards but nine out
of ten members are open to new
opportunities and with 70% of the US
workforce on LinkedIn posting there is
the best way to get your job opportunity
in front of more of the right people and
you can very very highly targeted and
specific people who are qualified for
the role you have and ready for
something new this is where you find
it's the best way to find that person
that key person will help you grow your
business and this is why a new hire is
made every 20 seconds using LinkedIn
that's bonkers every 10 seconds so head
to linkedin.com forward slash tim and
get $50 off your first job post
that's linkedin.com forward-slash Tim T
I am to get $50 off your first Java link
10.com forward slash Tim take a look
terms and conditions do this episode is
brought to you by Inc tell use them
personally ever since I wrote the 4-hour
workweek
I've been asked over and over again how
I choose to delegate tasks how I do
80/20 analysis and so on at the root of
many of those decisions is a simple
question initially two questions number
one how can I invest money to improve my
quality of life I use that an investing
as well
the second how can I spend a little
money or moderate money to save
significant time each tella is one of
those investments they're a turnkey
solution for all of your imaginable
customer care unions I used Intel during
the launch of the 4-hour body which was
very very involved and they provided
24/7 customer service for my landrush
campaign because it was critical for me
to take care of every person who
purchased my books and participated this
allowed me to focus on the things that I
am better at my strengths like the
marketing plan that we've worked on for
six months implementing the back intel
trains their experience customer service
reps to know your business and your
products inside and out and make your
customers raving fans they answer more
than a million customer service requests
every year and they can do so across all
platforms including email phone social
media texts and shadows leaving your
customers with poor service or just
mediocre service which by the way in a
competitive pool the huge liability long
wait times or unanswered messages
carries a massive cost and risk to your
business Intel removes the logistics and
headaches of this type of communication
allowing you to focus on your strengths
and grow
your business it can be a real predator
advantage and I see many many e-commerce
companies and the tech companies
thinking of customer service as a good
enough check box for an afterthought and
just like Airbnb you design and
innovative ways to be a competitor and
to win that you can do the same thing
with customer service so as a listener
of this podcast you can get up to ten
thousand dollars off its big discount
ten thousand dollars off your startup
fees and costs by visiting Inc Telecom
forward slash Tim so check it out more
info go to Inc Telkom i NK te l comma
four slash
[Applause]
you